vamos a conversar de la economía en el
fin de semana con Daniela Blandón
Daniela Un saludo para usted Hola Ángela
Qué tal Daniela bien gracias y vamos a
empezar hablando de la hoja de Coca
porque está cayendo drásticamente su
precio a qué se debe esta situación
Ángela Es que hay un fenómeno que viene
inquietando a gobiernos y a expertos en
temas de narcotráfico Y es que el precio
de la coca en Colombia que es el
principal productor mundial se ha
desplomado el último año de manera
inusual Los Campesinos de zonas
cocaleras que derivan su sustento de
esta actividad ilícita se están quedando
con la producción por falta de
compradores la oficina de Washington
para asuntos latinoamericanos que es una
ong que le sigue el pulso a la situación
de los cultivos ilícitos en la región
identifica varios factores que
explicarían lo que está pasando por un
lado una sobreoferta en la producción de
esta hoja de Coca pero también hay
cambios en la estructura de los carteles
por la captura de grandes líderes y
también un desplazamiento de los grupos
criminales hacia otros negocios más
rentables como el oro o el platino
Bueno qué otras hipótesis podrían
explicar este fenómeno hay que ahondar
un poco más en el tema no Claro que sí
la caída del precio de la hoja de coca
también puede explicarse en una aparente
cambio en los hábitos de consumo
especialmente en Estados Unidos que es
uno de los principales compradores Y en
donde las drogas sintéticas como el
fentanilo están desplazando la cocaína
Franz 24 contactó en Washington al
director de seguridad y de defensa de
bola Adam y saxon y esto nos dijo Es
cierto que la cocaína ya realmente
cuando se piensa en la crisis del uso de
drogas o abuso de drogas en Estados
Unidos no se piensa en la cocaína hay
una cifra récord de sobredosis muertos
de sobredosis en Estados Unidos pero la
cocaína es solo una porcentaje muy bajo
de eso estamos hablando de sobredosis de
instantáneo de heroína opioides
metanfetaminas cocaína casi no entra en
la historia dicho eso parece bueno según
las encuestas de los de la población que
usa droga de los incautaciones en la
frontera con México parece y de los
precios ha reportados en las calles
Parece que la oferta de cocaína sigue
más o menos igual en Estados Unidos de
siempre es solamente que la cocaína no
es la droga principal que que se usa en
este momento pues fíjense cómo van
cambiando los hábitos de consumo Y eso
aplica también para las sustancias Claro
que sí está ong de Derechos Humanos
estima que el precio del kilo de hoja de
Coca en las zonas productoras en
Colombia ha bajado más de 60% Durante
los últimos 12 meses en mayo de 2022 se
pagaba un dólar con 30 centavos por cada
kilo actualmente el precio es de 52
centavos de dólar por cada kilo
consultamos también al Vocero de bola
sobre este fenómeno si es estructural o
es circunstancial por lo porque lo que
usted dice es que como como usted bien
lo dice es que también hay que mirar
cómo se están comportando los los
consumidores que son al final determinan
estos precios
Sí yo creo que es una crisis temporal
es que el ser humano no está de repente
dejando de ser adicto a la cocaína
no vemos grandes cambios en el uso bueno
ha habido cambios graduales en Estados
Unidos pero en Brasil siguen usando
mucho la cocaína en Europa sigue siendo
muy rentable y hay mucho uso y no he
visto un declive importante del uso de
la cocaína ya
las fuerzas armadas y policía
colombianas siguen reportando
incautaciones especialmente en el
espacio marítimo que siguen más o menos
iguales que en los últimos años que
indica que la cocaína se está
produciendo como siempre yo creo que es
algo que tiene más que ver con
condiciones en el cambio en el campo de
Colombia Perú y a menor medida Bolivia
que probablemente se
en cuestión de un año no estaremos
hablando tanto de tanta tantos precios
tan bajos hay aquí también una teoría
simple de oferta y demanda porque se
habla de que hay una sobreoferta de la
hoja de Coca claro y cuando hay sobre
oferta pues los precios tienden a bajar
Y es que hay nuevos países incursionando
en el mercado de la producción y están
entrando a competirle directamente a
Colombia y a Perú que han dominado el
negocio por décadas como también lo
explica nuestro invitado Bueno
históricamente realmente a Colombia Perú
y Bolivia ha representado casi toda la
oferta de coca y cocaína pero en los
últimos años hemos visto importantes
cultivos y hasta laboratorios detectados
o destruidos en varios departamentos de
Colombia y Honduras en varios
departamentos de Guatemala y Honduras y
también en el sur de México no estamos
hablando estamos hablando de cientos
cientos de hectáreas Tal vez un poco más
en algunos de esos países y por supuesto
eso no compara con los 200.000 que se
encuentran en Colombia pero indica que
los narcotraficantes están probando
nuevos espacios y se está incrementando
en otros lugares y hay que tener cuidado
porque eso nos plantea nuevos riesgos en
otras áreas Daniela Naciones Unidas
también se ha pronunciado al respecto
claro dice que a pesar de la caída de
precios al productor de hoja de Coca el
negocio ilícito de la cocaína si sigue
creciendo en su más reciente reporte
global sobre la cocaína la oficina de
las Naciones Unidas contra la droga y el
delito informó que la oferta mundial de
esta sustancias se encuentra en niveles
récord alcanzando casi las 2.000
toneladas en 2020 y lo que ha hecho es
acentuar un repunte dramático que viene
desde 2014 y un comentario para
finalizar Y es que últimamente lo que se
ha visto es que con menos hojas de Coca
están produciendo más cocaína Porque se
están modernizando por decirlo así lo
que nos faltaba Muchísimas gracias
Daniela aquí nos vemos en una próxima
oportunidad a nuestros televidentes
continúen con nosotros en France 24 y
nos vemos pronto
[Música]